[Music]
hey you guys it's tuesday yeah this is a
great flick this is uh this flick here
is uh nicholas cage uh
playing luke skywalker
[Laughter]
he looks just like the luke skywalker
from the new uh
oh yeah that didn't really occur to me
to me nicholas cage always just looks
like nicolas cage and that's a good
thing you start to look like mark hamill
now nicholas cage you guys nicholas cage
is a national [ __ ] treasure i know he
was in national treasure i didn't mean
it but you know what i mean
in the same way i kind of feel like he's
gotten to a place
much like keanu reeves or something like
that where he's kind of like a beloved
like who the [ __ ] doesn't love
nicolas cage come on [ __ ] wow
but well the cool thing about this movie
though and i kind of feel like
um
like i said i admire the [ __ ] out of
nicolas cage just because he really
seems to i mean he's been in some
terrible movies he's been in some great
movies he's got to work man he's got to
pay those bills well but the thing about
it though is that he really seems to
love acting for the sake of the art form
he doesn't phone it in he [ __ ] gives
it his all absolutely yeah i mean there
are some of that we saw where he was
kind of like one of them we saw was like
a predator's predator rip-off that was
also kind of like a chinese martial arts
movie all mixed members oh yeah i
remember that what the hell was the name
of that thing god said it was terrible
but he was the only well he was good at
it he was interesting about the movie
yeah it was like a first person shooter
i can't remember what the name of that
movie was wild man i don't know we
watched it it was just like a predator
rip off pretty much yeah it was good
though uh that end of the badlands
ripoff he did a good job and if i didn't
like that movie either i mean he'll be
in it he'll be in that i mean he'll be
in some weird [ __ ] and like i said i
like
i like actors that'll do that though i
like actors that will be that will take
a chance on some bizarre ass movie yeah
uh you know and and like you said don't
phone it in i mean we said kind of the
same thing about david warner yesterday
he's not really incred he wasn't really
in crazy [ __ ] but sometimes he would be
in you know real crappy like bottom of
the barrel stuff but he never like no he
class it up he would class it up yeah so
and i always kind of feel like as an
actor because look hey man we all got to
eat okay
um you know everybody has had to take
jobs that they don't like
uh so you know mad respect and just just
if you and going in there and actually
like doing your best and like working
hard at it and just not making a joke
out of the whole thing like i said that
gets a lot of respect even if the movie
sucks uh that's going to get a lot of
sticklers cage
is the exact opposite
of of of of uh
i can
damn what's his name i just want to tip
my i have no idea who you're talking
about right now
steven seagal he's exactly the opposite
of steven seagal steven seagal will
phone it in on his own [ __ ] moves
his own project
i'm not even going to walk he's not
going to walk him off he's going to have
a [ __ ] snot double he won't even do
the voice
do the voices in his own projects i have
somebody else dubbing it i think we're
getting to a point where we're just
going to see a steven seagal movie that
just has like a picture of him and
they're just going to wave it in front
of the camera
but you know we i know we should we
should on the stephen's goal but i mean
he's so he's so [ __ ] honorable but we
only say that like to contrast it with
like i said with nicolas cage who seems
like a delightful human being he's nuts
sure but
nothing wrong with that we're all a
little nuts this is uh um this this this
uh movie is done by a first time
director it is
and uh
it's an excellent movie it's a it's shot
real well
it's uh kind of pulls you in
it uh [ __ ] up your expectations a lot
because that's the best thing about it i
thought and they're doing it on purpose
the movie's kind of in a way trolling
you because you go oh okay this is
nicholas cage
doing a uh [ __ ] um
uh what's the name of that damn movie
where he's uh
doing it when he's avenging the dog yeah
john wick john wick you go like oh this
is kind of like everybody thought that
this was going to be john wick with the
pig
and they know you're expecting that yes
so they [ __ ] with your mind this shit's
all sensitive and [ __ ] it's just [ __ ]
it's funny it's like the anti john wick
it's pretty much like the same story
story kind of
realism what would but what he really do
i was watching there's this really good
i can't remember who did it was i think
it's called in frame out yeah channel
and he did like a 14 minute like video
essay on this and he said a really
interesting thing he said um you know at
movies like taken or john wick or
something like that which this seemingly
is modeled after like if you just read a
plot synopsis um you think it's gonna go
that way and he's like where it's a
vengeance narrative and so you know
people have certain expectations about
that but this one is kind of like the
anti-thing of that where it's like the
same story but instead of going and like
whooping ass on all the people that
[ __ ] him over he basically just goes
and gives them like compassion yeah it
out cooks them and [ __ ] well and that
too yeah
he he he's he's like a gordon ramsay in
a way but not a dick well uh well he's
got he's kind of hard he's [ __ ] tough
but he's tough but he's like um he the
stuff that he says is out of compassion
for the person yeah yeah
yeah it's it's and you don't expect it
yeah everything is like [ __ ] you know
like what and um
but no he's a tough guy living up in the
mountains and he's got this damn truffle
pig that can [ __ ] find these
expensive truffles and you have a guy
whose dad owns a damn
real high-end restaurant who's coming up
there and buying those truffles from him
and he's up there making [ __ ]
he looks like he's on the edge of
survival living in a damn shack like up
in oregon yeah
but then like they'll have a whole scene
where he's like doing something and it
looks all hardcore and then he's making
a damn truffle tart
yeah yeah he doesn't mean it's like
like he did something [ __ ]
this like he did some action i love it
well i love anything to do i love
anything to do with like uh the culinary
world like anything to do with cooking
i'm like really into that kind of stuff
so i really like and i like that this
movie approaches it like the art world
like the high-end art world because i
like movies that are set in that uh
framework as well yeah there's an
element of kind of like organized almost
kind of like borderline organized crime
behind it and you know trying to steal
[ __ ] so they can have a better menu this
season it's just
yeah which i think is a little bit
i mean it's a little bit exaggerated
but i'm sure that [ __ ] does that because
there are people actually i didn't see
it but i heard a lot about um i don't
know if it was like right around the
same time this came out or like a few
months before a documentary came out
called the truffle hunters and it was
basically about people that do what
nicholas cage does in this movie where
they just kind of like live and they and
they have like um not necessarily a lot
of them use dogs as well too or you know
uh where they look for truffles and then
sell them to you know to the highest
bidder or whatever what look at the
reviews of this and it's well reviewed
everybody liked it and what's funny is
that like the reviews are saying like
this movie is awesome it is
action-packed they're [ __ ] trolling
you all right every [ __ ] action scene
has been replaced by him having a
serious talk with somebody or him
[ __ ] cooking some [ __ ]
well it's like but they portray it as if
it was yeah but that's see that's what i
like about it though because it's almost
kind of like some of the stuff that he
says you know in a in a more traditional
like revenge flick like john wick or
taken or something like that it would be
like you know an ass kicking but it's
almost like a verbal ass kick but not in
a mean way like i said he means it with
love it's worth watching it's an
entertainment entertaining movie it's a
pretty movie
it looks really good yeah i kind of feel
like don't like don't go into it
thinking it's going to be like i said
you know um you know john wick with a
pig because it is totally not that it's
almost kind of like the opposite of that
so it knows you're expecting that yeah
and so it goes into but i have to say
that the story behind it like him
going to find this pig which honestly he
goes out into the woods like the the
backstory the backstory that he has
which a lot of it is filled in really
nice like really organically like they
just give you like a little bit of
information at a time and apparently
back in the day uh he was this massively
known chef like in portland uh you know
in the foodie scene he was like
legendary like everybody knew who he was
and then like after his wife dies he
disappears he goes and lives in
isolation out in the cabin so it's
almost kind of like this pig which
doesn't really mean anything to anyone
else other than as a commodity uh you
know because it can find truffles but to
him he didn't really care about that i
mean the pig was the only thing left
that he cared about
and so
you know what i mean in much the same
way that john wick uh you know cared
about the puppy although i kind of feel
like in john wick he loved the puppy but
he loved the puppy more as a
representation because it was like the
last thing that his wife gave him yeah
before she was killed whereas in this
um nicolas cage actually does love this
pig it's his companion
and so you might have a sex patient no
yeah i don't mean it like that and then
like he's yeah it's platonic
they accuse him of that they do i mean
they would in real life so that's why no
he just
pigs his buddy yeah yeah he definitely
loves this pig you know they so they
show like some scenes of him at the
beginning like making food for the pig
it is i have to say it is that an
adorable pig it's a little it's a little
it's a little fuzzy pig yeah oh my god
really pig it's so cute um is that a pot
belly pig i think it's a pot belly
see i don't know i don't know what
species it's not a big pig it's the size
of a small dog yeah and it's kind of
fuzzy like it has kind of like reddish
brown fur but yeah super cute pig gotta
say but um but yeah so when the pig is
pig-napped you know
uh abducted
by some sketchy individuals
and then so he has to go back to
portland he's trying to trace back who's
story and trying to trace back like who
stole it and what happened to her and
like i said along the way he's sort of
like revisiting his past honestly the
one scene my favorite scene in this
movie was when he goes to that like uh
that upper crusty like hoity-toity
restaurant euridicy i think it's called
and he goes there and he talks to the
chef
who worked for him for two months like a
long time ago
and and he's basically like the guys
doing all that like fancy [ __ ]
nouveau cuisine kind of [ __ ] that like
gordon ramsay hates you know what i mean
like look i put it in a glass globe and
it's like all like smoke coming in and
it's all that no food in it and there's
no food on it it's like it's all that
kind of [ __ ] and uh so nicolas cage
has this very serious like talking to
with this guy about
his history yeah he's like you know what
happened to he's like you know these
people in here why do you care about
these people in this restaurant they
don't care about you they never they
don't know you like this isn't the kind
of [ __ ] you wanted to do i thought you
wanted to open a pub that was your
passion why didn't you ever do that so
it's just kind of like i didn't really
expect and i think a lot of people that
went into this movie uh thinking that it
was gonna be like a
traditional like revenge movie didn't
realize like how [ __ ] philosophical
this [ __ ] was gonna get and honestly
it's really
affecting yeah it's the movie is kind of
like got a certain zen to it yeah and
the the uh
the main character the chef ends up kind
of like
finding the zen and allowing things to
remain [ __ ] up in the end because
because everything is as it should be
that's what that's the that's kind of
the lesson like
that's how that's what i got from it but
he also set a bunch of [ __ ] straight the
the the there is kind of a buddhist
philosophy kind of behind them yeah
definitely it's uh
the movie it is it is a good watch
it
it is not action-packed in the way that
say like john wick is action-packed well
i mean john wick is like wall-to-wall
action pretty much right it's not that
kind of action no it's like emotional
action that's a good way of putting it
actually like i said a lot of times
where you know the beats in a revenge
movie would be an ass kicking or
something right because somebody gets
shot in the face yeah this will be like
a a stern dressing down yeah but in but
i'm making that sound like you know
facetious but i mean it in like the best
possible way yeah it is it does it is
pretty cool i mean he's coming out of
this shack and he won't [ __ ] bathe he
looks like a damn bum he's got crested
blood on the side of his face he looks
beat up because he's trying to survive
you know and there's all these people
trying to stop him from finding the
[ __ ] pig and he'll go into this
expensive restaurant you know what i
mean to sit down they want to throw his
ass out and then they realize who he is
and also he's in charge and then well
yeah because he's a [ __ ] legend yeah
and then his dirty ass will go back in
the damn kitchen and start cooking and
[ __ ]
they're all eating this
which that's all part of the movie
i mean it's so great and it easily
washed
yeah but for the if for the effects of
the movie he's no he's good well he
wanted every single
he wanted every single you know uh thing
that life had thrown at him to be
reflected he wanted everybody to see
that
you know what i'm saying right well
because at one point he has to go to
like this
underground fight club type of thing
uh and he gets punched in the face there
so there has there is actually a fight
in it but it's not you know he just kind
of lets himself get punched in the face
i will say too that i really like
the way
the quote-unquote bad guys in the movie
as the movie goes on like the people
that were that end up kind of being
behind uh you know the pig getting
stolen and characters like amir who is
played by alex wolf who is also great in
this by the way
um
who at first seem like not real
sympathetic because he just seems like
this young hot shot he's got like this
really obnoxious like yellow sports car
and he kind of
seems like insecure about he comes from
a really wealthy family and he's always
like listening to tapes about classical
music like trying to class himself up
because he feels like he's not good
enough for some [ __ ] so there's always
that kind of thing so he seems not kind
of obnoxious at first but then as the
movie goes on like everybody gets like
more and more sympathetic
um which i thought was like a really
good i don't know i just thought it was
like a really good way of going about it
this seems like i've i don't know if
this is gonna happen but
uh there definitely has been
kind of like some
a lot of uh things that i saw about oh
he should have got nominated for an
oscar for this which
i mean it's it's just
i don't know i liked it because it was
really like i said playing on not only
expectations of revenge thrillers uh you
know in action movies but also playing
on nicholas cage's
reputation
uh for cage rage because you're kind of
like expecting him to just like [ __ ]
bust out they're asking it's not on
netflix no it's on hulu john hulu
hillary yeah um you might be able to i'm
sure you can probably rent it on amazon
prime as well
uh but we watched it on hulu it's free
on there so i'm not sure about other
streaming services but that's where we
watched it yeah but um this actually got
a limited theatrical release last summer
so
i don't know
um
i think that i mean nicolas cage got
nominated for uh
at the critics choice awards for best
actor but i don't know about
oscar [ __ ] although that when this came
out and it was getting reviewed like a
lot of people were talking about maybe
he should get an oscar for it which
you know i i wouldn't be mad i just i
really liked this movie
yeah and um but just you know it's kind
of better
i don't know it depends on what kind of
person you are i guess if you're
expecting it to be an action movie and
you're going to be pissed off that it's
not then probably then don't watch it
but if you like being surprised by
things if you like because i thought it
was going to be like john wick as well
i think i even said that when we were
watching it i said oh he's going to go
john wick on a [ __ ] yeah he did
but he doesn't and it's like i was just
kind of like oh keep waiting for him to
go but he never does yeah he goes about
things in a much different way like you
said it's a very buddhist yeah type of
movie which like i said i really really
liked it if you're a nicholas cage fan
you'll like the movie it's good yeah i
kind of feel like you probably will
uh tyler says nicholas cage gets no
respect yeah well i don't know about
that he gets respect i think he does um
he does
he kind of like i said he's sort of
around he's
doesn't really like like he because i
feel like in the 90s and [ __ ] like that
he did in the 80s i guess he did a lot
of kind of big hollywood movies and
stuff and after a while he was just kind
of like he didn't like that because it
was just too he thought it was too
constricting
um yeah and he thought well you know
it's all about the bottom line and he
didn't really like that he wanted to do
something more interesting or more
creative and so like i said you really
have to respect that even though a lot
of movies that he's in you know are not
that good
i don't know if i'd say a lot but we've
seen some movies that were not that
great but he's always the best thing in
it and like you said he always like
pretty much gives it a hundred and ten
percent that's when the movie shitty
yeah they could tell him he probably or
he has the
he has the instincts this is gonna be a
shitty movie so then he starts [ __ ]
going over the top and it so at least he
delivers yeah okay
it does make the movie better that he
went over the top on it you know
even wicker man a lot of you didn't like
that it wasn't as good as the original
but his version of wickerman was
different his version
would have [ __ ] us blown chucks if he
wasn't in it
well yeah the best thing about it it
totally wouldn't have worked yeah it was
the best thing about that him being in
it made it into like a so bad it's good
classic yeah like unintentionally would
have been forgotten without him in it
actually if since it's nicholas cage
we're talking about i don't even know if
it was unintentional maybe the
filmmakers
didn't intend it but nicholas cage
seemed like he sure intended it
you know what he was dealing with he's
like this movie sucks a lot i'm just
gonna like go way out on a limb and make
this the craziest [ __ ] ever yeah so
people will remember it just and it
worked at least fondly in that way when
he done that boot had he done that [ __ ]
in a different way or straight or has
somebody else done that movie it would
have just been forgotten yeah he made
that movie i mean look at what he did in
mandy yeah which god damn it i i [ __ ]
love that one that movie is like one of
the best movies of all times
it really is i just love that him just
like sitting on the toilet in his
underwear like screaming like covered in
blood and stuff just so great he's he he
is
a great actor but he's also just like a
great artist yeah he's an art he's he's
an artist well i think that that's what
really resonated with me about pig was
that
at its heart it's like it's not only
about you know kind of grief and
accepting you know loss and things like
that but it's also about
being real to your artistic self like
not doing things just as a commodity not
doing things just for money doing things
that you're actually like passionate
about and so i think that's like a
really cool like through line that goes
through the whole movie and him going
around
you know telling people that and getting
them to you know find their zen or
whatever the hell but i just i just
really really liked that kind of like
message so like i said it was really
like a resonant for me i think it would
be a trip to have a drink with i [ __ ]
know i know oh gosh yeah dude yeah i
would totally like to hang out with
nicholas gage i really would uh danny
rolling he probably is he's yeah like i
said he's probably a barrel of laughs so
there's a honestly i wouldn't mind
hanging out with keanu either actually
wouldn't that be awesome if you could
hang out with nicholas cage and keaney
yeah
that would be cool counter reasons
call us
probably just talk about guns and
motorcycles with him all night see you
love that yeah he's he he likes
specifications and numbers see i love
how everything where things came from
tyler says leaving las vegas was my
favorite yeah that was that was a great
movie i mean he's been in so many
[ __ ] good ones i even liked him in a
lot of like the 80s ones like valley
girl and stuff like that he's fantastic
yeah i think this one as far as just our
you know artistically this one was going
to go down real well this uh this movie
will his fans will remember this one
yeah and i mean it's gotten almost
universal praise i feel like uh and it
came out neon put it out but i kind of
feel it almost feels like an a24 movie a
little bit see it's it's kind of an art
flick
it is it is so you know [ __ ] i guess
you could say the art
the art film
critics will go oh yes that's great and
then just
then just you know his fans
[ __ ]
like it they're gonna like it just
because he's in it and he does a great
job he's [ __ ] hilarious at it even
though it's it's not funny it's kind of
funny you just gotta
it's it's a lot of it's a movie that's
working on a lot of different levels at
the same time you just got to see it
well i love that they took what sounds
like an absurd premise and made like
this beautiful philosophical meditation
about it i mean that's so awesome yeah
and you expected it to be an action
movie i just i love that and you
expected it to be an action movie i just
love the whole like idea and i love
seeing somebody but it feels like it's
going to bust out into an action movie
at any time and they're doing that on
purpose yeah definitely yeah
um danny rolling ghostface what's
tomorrow's topic jenny tomorrow we are
going to be talking about
the tragic episode in american history
notice the tuskegee syphilis experience
oh yeah yeah by a war it's the bio
biological experiments on [ __ ] black
dudes yeah yeah it's it's very very sad
so yeah we're gonna be talking about
that tomorrow night so i'm sure that'll
be real cheerful but you know what are
you gonna do
that's the kind of show this is yeah
these are the fun ones the movie reviews
but yeah so uh we're gonna check off
like i said um i'm gonna check off that
sounds nasty did you check off or anton
check off okay yeah
it's not just check off like that or
we're leaving
uh because we have another movie review
we have to record
so
be sure to come by tomorrow evening at 5
p.m eastern standard time for our
regular live stream episode and uh we
will see you guys
then
bye